[Musique]
aussi loin que je me souvienne je n'ai
jamais su quoi faire de ma vie
bon c'est vrai je n'ai jamais su quoi
faire de ma vie et cela m'a souvent valu
d'être taxée de kohsar flemmards ou
encore paresseux par mon père moi
évidemment je voyais pas ça comme ça je
me revendiquer davantage comme un hindou
rêveur un poète un idéaliste et combien
de fois je me suis retrouvé la boule au
ventre face à l'urgence de cette
question qu'est ce que tu vas faire de
ta vie mais c'est vrai ça qu'est ce que
j'allais faire de ma vie alors je me
disais que je n'étais peut-être pas le
seul qui avait d'autres doux rêveur peut
être idéaliste qui partageait avec moi
l' angoisse de cette question
existentielle
aujourd'hui je sais que nous sommes
nombreuses et nombreux
il y en a peut-être même parmi vous il
ya peut-être même parmi vous des parents
dont les enfants présenteraient le même
profil que moi et voyez ils peuvent être
rassurés
cela les empêchera pas de faire un tête
dans leur vie parce que au fond c'est
pas dramatique de ne pas savoir ce qu'on
va faire dans la vie ça vous empêche pas
de savoir qui vous voulez devenir ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que ne pas
avoir de réponse à cette question
ça peut sera dur aussi comme une
capacité à rester vivant à s'émerveiller
à essayer a échoué évidemment mais aussi
à réussir bref à tomber constamment
amoureux au fond la vraie question pour
ne pas tellement autour de ce qu'on fait
dans la vie non mais plutôt qu'est ce
qui fait que vous aimez votre vie qu'est
ce qui vous fait vous lever tous les
matins je sais pas moi ce que c'est
votre amoureuse votre amoureux votre
famille vos amis vos enfants vos
passions aux accomplissements votre
travail
j'imagine que c'est un peu tout ça
évidemment moi je vois un peu mieux
pourquoi pourquoi j'aime ma vie j'aime
ma vie et je sais que c'est un privilège
de pouvoir dire ça ça paraît simple
pour autant on sait tous
que les choses ne sont pas toujours si
simple dans la vie moi enfant j'ai tout
de la nourriture de l'affection et du
temps je suis un vrai coq en pâte
rien ne presse et je suis tranquille
laventure les voyages c'est pas
tellement mon truc ça faisait même peut
être un peu peur bon j'avoue j'étais un
peu tendu sur les bords à l'école je
suis il élève studieux j'ai à coeur de
bien faire les choses pour qu'on me
laisse bien peinard en revanche à
travers mes yeux la préoccupation
c'était de pas me faire voir ne pas me
faire remarquer et je voyais d'urgence
du regard des autres
finalement enfants ma seule
préoccupation c'est de me dire que
j'étais bien là j'étais français j'étais
normand mais je devais le revendiquer
sans cesse alors mon urgence à moi
c'était quoi c'était me trouver une
place dans ce monde là justement pour
pour garder cette tranquillité alors
évidemment j'avais mes petits stratégie
vite fait bien fait j'étais du genre de
d'enfants à rentrer dès le vendredi soir
pour faire ses devoirs et tranquille
pendant tout le week-end et et profiter
avec les copains à l'époque je me
souviens je voulais te django reinhardt
alors si j'avais pu je crois je serais
venu ici avec une fine moustache vous
savez ce génial guitariste manouche
c'était mon guitar hero je voulais jouer
et vivre comme lui mais l'ambition mois
les voyages s'était pas tellement mon
truc mais pour une fois je trouvais ça
sa vie de bohème et de caravanes
tellement inspirante et puis sa musique
quelle claque
vous connaissez probablement mais la
virtuosité dans les tempos rapides les
sentiments dans les ballades il ya tout
dans cette musique là et puis ce que
j'aime bien dans cette musique enfin je
crois c'est que pour bien jouer cette
musique là il faut jouer avec ses tripes
et avec son coeur et je voulais que ça
dure le plus longtemps possible
et puis c'est aussi à ce moment de ma
vie où j'ai senti que j'avais ce qu'on
appelle une passion c'est à ce moment de
ma vie que j'ai compris que je
commençais à m'approprier quelque chose
d'important c'était cette place dans ce
monde là et c'est aussi à ce moment là
de ma vie que
je me suis posé cette question bête
simple est ce que finalement pour être
heureux la clé ce ne serait pas de vivre
de ce qu'on aime alors moi j'ai pas eu
le courage de me lancer dans une
carrière de musicien
j'étais peut-être pas assez bon c'est
certain mais je crois surtout que ça ne
m'intéressait pas de devenir
professionnel d'avoir un métier
moi ce que je voulais finalement c'était
profiter des sensations et des émotions
que ça me procure et la musique ok passe
ton bac d'abord et après tu feras ce que
tu voudras ça je reconnais que je les ai
pas mal entendu cette phrase là et j'ai
suivi les conseils de mes parents repas
conseille plutôt une injonction je vous
adore mes parents mais ça ressemble
quand même à une injonction
alors je vais faire j'ai fait un bac s
et puis après j'ai allégé choisi
médecine pourquoi médecine parce que
médecine
ça a ressemblé à une garantie à vie
d'une forme de tranquillité
un salaire un statut une reconnaissance
alors sa première fin de ma vie aussi où
j'ai travaillé dur où j'étais besogneux
g charbonnet le résultat fut pas si
mauvais je suis arrivé à 14 places de
médecine mais bon insuffisant inutile de
vous dire que la déception sujet quand
est pas tellement par le fait que je
n'ai pas une médecine mais par le fait
que je travaillais beaucoup pour une
fois et que j'ai échoué au pied du mur
alors il faut rebondir
et en plus vous répondre à l'urgence de
qu'est ce que tu vas faire dans ta vie
alors j'ai choisi biologie enfin ça
ressemble plus à un choix par défaut
parce que biologie c'est une passerelle
possible lorsqu'on échoue en médecine et
moi je trouvais que ça ressemblait
plutôt à un lot de compensation alors
assez tranquillement je dois dire je
suis allé plus loin que je pouvais aller
j'ai vu de la lumière j'allais là où
c'était possible j'ai enchaîné avec
licence un master puis un doctorat en
neuroscience cognitive
les gens me dit souvent ça c'est dingue
c'est super un doctorat en neuroscience
cognitive
ils ont raison c'est c'est vraiment
super et passionnant et pour autant
faire ces études là ça me conforter dans
l'idée que je savais ce que j'allais
faire de ma vie des sciences mais au
fond de moi je savais que je ne sentais
pas ce truc là je voulais pas devenir
neuroscientifique professionnel je
savais qu'au fond de moi ça ne me
faisait pas plus vrai que ça alors pour
résumer je me retrouvais avec un très
très beau diplôme sur les bras
qui ne servaient pas directement et je
courrais derrière une vie sans trop
savoir à quoi elle ressemblait je me
cherchais quoi je suis pas le seul
j'imagine que on est plein à cette
recherche et dans notre vie et vous
savez quand on se cherche
comme si on fait face à un problème
insurmontable à une espèce de vide
immense
le vide en soit ça fout les jetons mais
ça a du bon parce que ya pas de place
pour le superflu dans le vide et je
crois naturellement qu'on cherche tous à
combler ce vide à le remplir et à le
remplir de la meilleure manière qui soit
moi à ce moment-là je me rappelle je me
cherche évidemment j'étais perdu et il
m'arrivait un événement malheureux je
perdais quelqu'un d'important dans ma
vie je perdais un oncle cet oncle l'a
justement qui m'avait transmis cet amour
pour la guitare et django reinhardt
tout ça pour vous dire que ce genre de
choc
ça va avoir un impact évidemment sur la
vie des gens sur nos existences en ce
qui me concerne ce choc
cet événement m'a montré qu' il était
comme urgent d'être heureux cet
événement a montré que dorénavant
j'écouterai juste mon coeur pour me
guider dans la vie alors ce vide je les
remplis non je n'ai pas juste rempli les
saturer de choses que j'aimais faire de
la musique
évidemment que je portais comme un
héritage familial désormais faire la
fête profitez des gens que j'aime rester
insouciant mais soucieux des autres
alors à cette époque là je gagnais pas
un rond mais qu'est-ce que j'étais bien
j'étais bien et bien loin de cette
question de ce que j'allais faire dans
la vie mais j'étais conscient de ce que
je vivais alors je me suis dit que ce
serait pas mal si je pouvais conserver
précieusement ses souvenirs pour me dire
que je peux en profiter encore et encore
et encore alors je me suis mis à
m'intéresser à la photographie c'est
marrant parce que
la photographie et ma famille c'est une
très longue histoire une longue histoire
d'amour qui qui s'étend sur plusieurs
générations
mon père mon grand père et mon arrière
grand père était photographe
professionnelle des artisans dans ce
qu'il ya de plus noble
à croire que c'était génétique cette
affaire dans sourire jusqu alors ça
m'intéressait pas plus que ça moi je
file un coup de main à mon père en
boutique
on reporte un jeu quelques fois je me
souviens bien de l'odeur des bacs
chimiques mais ça s'arrêtait là et je ne
serais vraiment pas vous dire pourquoi à
ce moment c'est comme si cet héritage
familial jaillissait soudainement et je
me suis mis à fond j'avais la chance
parce que j'étais à bonne école et j'ai
appris à cadrer à composer à exposer à
comprendre une image sous le regard de
mon père et comme en photo je retrouvais
des sensations exceptionnelles des
sensations qui me permettait d'être
connecté avec l'instant présent et je
voulais que ça dure le plus longtemps
possible
je voulais que ça dure le plus longtemps
possible ok en fait elle était là la
réponse a été sous mes yeux c'était la
même réponse
en fait je crois que comme tous les doux
rêveurs poète et idéaliste ce que je
voulais c'était une vie d'indépendants
une vie d'artiste
ce que je voulais c'était une vie
d'indépendants et une vie d'artiste
génial j'ai trouvé la réponse mais en
fait c'est pas très original ça vivre de
la photo la photo ça intéresse plein de
monde
je trouve même d'ailleurs que est un peu
trop de doux rêveurs pourrait t'aider à
liszt qui veulent faire de la photo
enfin bref
et puis à l'heure actuelle faire de la
photo à l'heure des smartphones contre à
bâle dans nos poches
c'est suicidaire non et puis les gens
vous le diront la photo c'est pas un
métier c'est une passion non bah oui
mais justement c'est parce que c'est une
passion que j'ai choisi ce métier là
alors
j'aurais pu vous raconter ça une belle
histoire vous dire que j'ai perpétuer la
tradition familiale
mais pour être honnête j'aurais jamais
imaginé que je serais passé derrière
deux scientifiques ont même métier que
mon père mon père d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il était un peu fier mais ils
m'encourageaient pas spécialement dans
cette voie parce que il voyait sa
profession de plus en plus fragilisé et
voulait pas ça pour moi évidemment il
savait bien que entre bien vivre de la
photographie et aimer la photographie il
ya un monde
mais malgré lui malgré moi
chemin faisant et sans savoir j'étais
devenu un enfant de la balle
aujourd'hui ça fait un peu plus de cinq
ans que je suis photographe à temps
plein j'ai envie plutôt bien mais
surtout je suis heureux de pouvoir vous
dire que la passion elle m'a quitté elle
m'a quittée parce que maintenant je suis
devenu complètement amoureux de mon
métier aussi difficile soit-il en regard
fier bresson disait photographier c'est
mettre sur la même ligne de mire la tête
l'oeil est le coeur et je crois que ma
vie ç'a toujours été un peu ça essayer
tant bien que mal de mettre sur la même
ligne de mire ma tête mon oeil et mon
coeur alors je ne suis pas sûr grenard
tenait pas sa flamboyance je n'ai pas
non plus la poésie d'un françois cheng
et encore mois le regard mystérieux de
viviane ailleurs je ne réinvente pas la
roue
je ne suis pas exceptionnel et c'est pas
le plus important
j'apprends à devenir ce que j'ai
toujours voulu être quelqu'un qui est à
sa place
quelqu'un qui est connecté à son univers
et à celui des autres bonsoir
je m'appelle julien et je fais un métier
qu'on qualifie volontiers de métier
passion je ne sais pas ce que vous
faites dans la vie et ce n'est pas la
question
en revanche j'espère de tout coeur que
vous prenez le temps d'aimer qui vous
êtes
je sais pas vous mais moi je vais
continuer à garder l'oeil ouvert et le
coeur battant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]